jennifer
is with us in atlantic city hi jennifer
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave and chris thank you so much for
taking my call i really appreciate it
sure
okay i live in new jersey and um
this summer we i was notified by ezpass
in new jersey that um our payment wasn't
being processed
um so i called easy pass
to correct the issue with my credit card
but of course this summer
no one was working in ez pass i couldn't
get a hold of anyone because of covid
everybody's working from home i tried
my husband tried anyway we ended up
changing the information online with the
credit card straightening it out
what we thought was for ourselves and i
just went to my mailbox and i just found
out we were
reported to collections because the
situation that we thought
was rectified was indeed not
so it is truly no fault of our own
um we're just having a hard time in the
state of new jersey
trying to get any kind of public
employee
to respond so i'm just curious
um what do i do now it's 175
i'm going to say the total charge was
maybe 75
[Music]
well um you know this is not the first
time i've heard easy pass sucks
um you've heard that before too haven't
you jennifer
absolutely yeah i mean this they kind of
have a reputation like comcast
you know it's just like yeah it's like
oh when you hear it you just go oh it's
hard to find intelligent life over there
it's like the dmv or something um so
and then worse than that they all decide
not to work so um
you know work from home entails work but
not
for everyone so um ouch
so what are you saying you you your bit
you did not pay your bill on time
because the account was screwed up
you went online thought you fixed it and
it was still screwed up
yes but it kept on saying you have to
speak to someone
um you have to talk to someone from
ezpass to correct this problem
and you never tried yeah and we could
this summer we couldn't and we just
assumed
okay well we updated the information
ourselves i guess we're okay
but then today i go and i find out now
it's up to 175
and we've been reported to collections
i've never been reported to collection
well there's no it's not like it's not
like they're going to come to your house
or something don't worry about it
they're not working that hard
um so and collection is just aggravating
i mean
it may have dinged your credit or
something but whoop-de-doop-dee it's not
the end of the world
uh i i i don't know what to tell you i
mean you're asking me how to motivate a
government employee i don't know how to
tell you how to do that
um okay you know i'm sorry i'm being
smart at like but it's also the truth i
mean how do you how do you
get somebody who can't lose their job
for incompetence to work
yes um i'm i'm being feeling very
frustrated yeah
angry yeah i get you i'm so
uh or you know i mean it'd be okay if
they said look
uh we're not gonna charge you anything
because we're not getting our work done
over here that's different
but instead they're like trying to ding
you like triple for for this thing
so um i don't know what i would do in
this situation is i would just continue
to be a bother to them
until i got it fixed and i don't know i
mean you know just like every morning i
gotta get up i gotta make my easy pass
call
and then we'll go on with the rest of
our day until we get somebody with a
brain
plug two brain cells to rub together to
try to get our way work through this
problem and get this charge removed
down to the original charge and then get
it paid i don't know what else to tell
you i don't have a good answer for you
but i do share your frustration you can
tell